Ezra's deaf and speech impaired she used
to sell boiled eggs to tourists at the
ski resort of Melhem Java to make money
for her family that's where she
developed her love of skiing but with
her appearance unable to afford normal
skis her brother carved wooden boards
for her to learn on what I am very poor
and earn hardly anything to make a
living but I'm still supporting her and
bringing her here every day to ski but
I'm worried about how she will achieve
her dreams despite all those
difficulties Ezra has become one of the
best students in a ski school Ezra is a
very bright girl and she picks things up
very quickly I teach my other students
verbally but I teach her through
demonstration and she's so talented that
she won a gold medal in recent
competition Melhem jarba and the Swat
valley is the only ski resort open to
the public in Pakistan and facilities
such as the chairlift have just been
rebuilt after they were destroyed by
years of fighting between the army and
the Pakistan Taliban as peace returns to
the area an increasing number of events
are being planned and with her friends
help Ezra says she's looking forward to
further success she says she enjoys
skiing she loves it and has a passion
for it she wants to participate in
international tournaments and be the
fastest skier in the world at 12 years
old
Ezra has dreams of reaching the Olympics
her coach says with time and proper
resources she can beat anyone paul
vanderwerff al-jazeera